i'm joined by one of the figures that's
still in that's tom tugan hat chair of
the foreign affairs select committee um
mr tugan hat you got today 37
votes you're still in the contest but
according to the yougov
members poll you get the backing first
choice of just eight percent surely
given that you only got 37 out of
uh somewhere in the region 358 tory mps
you're not going to tell me
the momentum's with you are you i
absolutely am and i'm going to tell you
that for the very simple reason that
your survey there reflects the fact of
knowledge of various of the candidates
and of course it's true that some are
got greater name awareness than others
but it's also true that colleagues who
know me who actually have worked with me
in many different ways have demonstrated
their confidence and that's exactly why
we've got the momentum we've got the
momentum because we're talking about a
clean start many of us have really had
enough of quite a lot of the actions of
the last few months and years and we're
all ready for a clean start in this
government so that we can have a
government that serves the people and a
conservative party that serves its
members now to get into that last two
that puts you in front of the membership
that allows you access tv debates and to
put your face around the country you
need another 90 or so votes uh in order
to achieve that where on earth are they
going to come from given that
only 37 are back to you so far well sam
you're not going to be at all surprised
to hear that i am not going to tell you
exactly who i'm talking to and uh
exactly where we're having these
conversations but it's not going to
surprise you either to hear that there
are a lot of conversations happening
tonight and will no doubt be happening
in the morning to jeremy hunt and uh
we're going to be talking to a lot of
people uh of course we're going to be
speaking to a lot of people and there's
still a hell of a long way to go yet um
now the two people that were knocked out
today uh jeremy hunt whose campaign
never really seemed to get much momentum
and nadim zahawi who had
quite a lot of promise many thought at
the start this campaign but seems to
have had a lot of uh
negative briefing about him accusations
around his tax affairs what do you make
of the way this race is being conducted
well look i think the way that uh people
have treated nadine to highways utterly
disgraceful because the briefing against
him has been completely unacceptable
what we need to do is we need to have a
clean campaign what we are doing here is
we are running a democratic campaign in
order to allow the membership of our
party to choose from the two members of
parliament who actually
enjoy the support of most of their
colleagues now that's a really important
thing to do it's massively important
because whoever wins is going to be the
prime minister of the united kingdom and
lead us into the next general election
you're making a serious charge here uh
you say uh that there's been disgraceful
briefing against nadine's hallway what
are you talking about and who's behind
it well i can't tell you who's behind it
all i can say is that these stories have
appeared uh seemingly from nowhere uh at
a very very in
brief moment uh and with very poor
sourcing
there are always a lot of rough and
tumble stories at the time of the
leadership election you're singling out
the treatment of nadine zahawi i mean
his supporters might end up coming over
to your camp if you play your cards
right
is this a tactical play to try and get
some of nadine to halway's supporters on
side or do you can you identify specific
things that you think stand out more
than the usual kind of hurley burleigh
of the tory leadership contest no this
is fundamentally about cleanliness and
politics this is exactly what we are
campaigning for in my team that's
exactly what i'm arguing for and that's
exactly why i'm standing to lead this
great party because i'm standing for a
clean start because we've seen the
issues that have arisen over recent
months and years and sadly we seem to
see some of them again and what we
really need to see is we need to see a
complete refresh of the conservative
party's way of doing things now actually
there are fantastic colleagues here
there are amazing colleagues in council
chambers across the country and i know
what they want to they want a clean
start based on the values of
conservatism based on the values of the
united kingdom and frankly just
to have a proper debate to have a proper
competition of ideas so that we get the
best two candidates from parliament put
before the membership but what we also
get is the members choice now there is a
lot of briefing all over the place for
instance nadine doris today talking
about there being some kind of coup when
it comes to ousting boris johnson
there's an anyone but rishi campaign
that's going on beneath the surface here
you don't single out either of those two
things do you think that actually this
race is fairly unedify well i certainly
think that what we need to do is to have
uh reagan's principle applied
conservatives should not speak ill of
fellow conservatives because frankly
whatever happens whoever wins
when i'm in number 10 as leader of this
party what we need to be doing is to
bring the party together now already i'm
delighted to say that my campaign has
brought together people from all wings
of the party and actually all parts of
the united kingdom so being
that person who can unify the party is
going to be absolutely essential to
bring the party together and to winning
the next general election final question
the person with observable momentum in
terms of mps backing them support in the
uh touring membership uh poll is penny
morden would you serve in her cabinet
look at the moment i am very very
focused on one thing i am absolutely
focused on winning this leadership
election and i tell you with the
momentum that we've got i'm absolutely
confident that we will